Merhaba ben TED Atakent kolejinden Beren
Tunalı 10 sınıf öğrencisiyim ve bugün
Sürdürülebilir kalkınmada eğitimli
döneminden bahsetmek için buradayım peki
sizce neden bu konuyu seçmiş olabilirim
Çünkü Tıpkı diğer gençler gibi ben de
hayat dediğimiz yola adımını atmış bir
gencim hepimizin önünde uzun bir yol var
önem verdiğimizde
amaçları ve hayalleri de var bazılarımız
ise hala bu amacın ne olduğunu bulmak
için çalışıyoruz
Ancak şu anda İçinde bulunduğumuz
şartlarda
geleceğin belirsizliği de çok açık ve bu
da ister istemez bizi kaygılandırıyor O
halde size bir soru sormama izin verin
Sizce şu anda uygulanan eğitim sistemi
tüm potansiyelimizi açığa çıkarmamıza
katkı sağlıyor mu Ya da yeterli mi
Hayır diyenleri ya da emin olamayanları
duyar gibiyim O halde bugün Soru sormaya
devam ederek bazı cevaplara hep birlikte
ulaşmaya çalışalım örneğin; neleri
yanlış yapıyoruz
yanlışlarımızın farkındaysak bunları
düzeltmek için bir adım atıyor muyuz
veya istediğimiz doğruları elde
edemiyorsak bu noktada amaçlarımızı
prensiplerimizi veya kullandığımız
yöntemleri tekrar gözden geçiriyor muyuz
bu soruları sorarak başlamak hem
kendimize hem de dünyayı tanımamız için
atmamız gereken Belki de ilk adım
Ancak ben bu soruları eğitim
perspektifinde cevaplamadan önce İçinde
bulunduğumuz dünyayı daha iyi
anlamlandırabilmek adına
Daha da doğrusu sanayileşme ve
modernleşmeden itibaren insanoğlunun
evrildiği materyalist düzene birazcık
açıklık getirmek istiyorum Çünkü her
nesil kendi koşullarına göre eğitime yön
verir
O halde bir çark hayal edin hiç durmadan
işlemeye devam eden bir çark bu Çarkın
sürekli dönmesini sağlayan da bazı
emekçileri var ama bu sistemde
emekçilerinin Arzu ve istekleri dikkate
alınmıyor Çünkü bu çark öyle bir
mühendislik bilgisi kullanılarak
hesaplanmış ki herkese bir iş bölümü
düşüyor kimse bu çörek ne için dönüyor
diye sorgulamıyor ya da dönem bu Çarkın
Kime nasıl bir yarar sağladığını da
kimse düşünmüyor tekrar hatırlatıyorum
emekçiler onlara Zorla dayatılan bu iş
bölümüne ayak uydurmak zorundalar Çünkü
bir şekilde geçimlerini sağlamalı ve
hayatlarına devam ettirmeliler
kendi potansiyellerini özgürce
kullanabilmekten mahrum bırakılmalarına
rağmen
bu şekilde hayatlarına devam ediyorlar
devam etmeye zorlatılıyorlar O halde
size soruyorum Sizce gerçekten
yaşıyorlar mı yoksa sadece var olarak
bu makinenin canlı bir parçası haline mi
geliyorlar Bana kalırsa sadece var
olarak bu makinenin canlı bir parçası
haline geliyorlar ne kadar acı değil mi
size ne anlattım aslında biliyor musunuz
bu kanal Marx'ın kapitalist sistemde
yabancılaşmaya nasıl bir gözle baktı
Aslında ona göre bu sistemde zorla
çalışmak durumunda olan emekçiler Yani
insanlar bir rutinin içine giriyorlar
kendi dualarından ve özlerinden
uzaklaşıyorlar ve en sonunda da
kendilerine yabancılaşıyorlar
çalıştıkça tükeniyorlar tükendikçe de
varlıklarının önemini unutuyorlar
hayattan zevk almıyorlar adeta birer
robot haline geliyorlar
durun ve şu anda İçinde bulunduğumuz
sisteme bir bakın herkesin aynı
doğrultuda hareket etmesi bekleniyor
herkesin hayat çizgisi aynı yönde
çizilmiş
tüm farklılıklarımıza rağmen aynı olmaya
zorlatılıyoruz herkes için zaman çarkı
farklı işlemiyormuş gibi bir de herkesin
aynı anda aynı şeyi yapması bekleniyor
bu hayat çizgisi de genellikle şöyle
ilerliyor üniversiteden sonra bir meslek
sahibi olmak para kazanmaya başlamak
birikim yapmak E peki sonra ne oluyor ya
Ev ve araba almanın hayalini
kuruyorsunuz ya da eğleniyorsunuz ne
kadar materyalist bir dünyada
yaşadığımızın farkında mısınız ve Sizce
gerçekten sadece bu kadar mı olmalı
Hayatınız boyunca size çizilen yoldan
yürüyorsunuz başka Yolları denemekten
korkuyorsunuz Ve sonunda neyin farkına
varıyorsunuz biliyor musunuz hayatınızı
kendiniz için yaşamamışsınız aslında
Peki biz bu noktaya nasıl geldik ya da
her şeyin kilit noktası ne
Ben söyleyeyim eğitim
bunca söylemleri uygulamalara ve daha
birçok şeye rağmen neden şu anda
uygulanan eğitimin çıktıları istediğimiz
yönde değil Hiç düşündük mü Belki de
okulları nasıl insan yetiştirdiğine
bakarsak bu sorunun cevabını daha net
verebiliriz Çünkü bizlere hata
yapmamamız gerektiği öğretiliyor öyle
bir algı oluşturulmuş ki Hata yapmaktan
korkuyoruz Risk almaktan denemekten yeni
bir yoldan gitmekten korkuyoruz Sanki
tek bir şansımız varmış ve hata yaparsak
bütün şansımızı kaybedecekmişiz gibi
Hayır Hayat öyle değil tek bir yol tek
bir çözüm tek bir cevap yok ve tüm bu
cevaplara çıkan yolda anahtar da aslında
eğitim
eğitim bir süreçtir aslında bir hayatı
hazırlanma aşaması değil Hayatın
kendisidir geçmiş Ya da gelecekte değil
tam olarak şu andadır
ilgi ve yeteneklerimizi tutkularımızı
keşfetmemizi sağlayan bir yoldur eğitim
asla ve asla Durağan değildir sürekli
devam eder ancak eğitimi sadece okul ve
akademik derslerden ibaret zannedenler
Öğretim adına yaptıklarını eğitim adı
altında lanse ediyorlar yanlış
öğretimle
işte bu noktada iyi bir eğitim
felsefesinin temelleri neye dayanmalıdır
diye sorarsanız Benim cevabım da bu
olacak
öğretimden çok eğitime öncelik
verdiğimiz bir sistemle sadece Sayısal
verilerle donatılmış öğrenciler yerine
Kültür Sanat ve ahlak alanlarında da
nitelikli bireylerin yetişmesini
sağlandığı bir sistem iyi bir eğitim
felsefesine dayanır
maddiyattan çok maneviyata değer veren
empati yapabilen kendi kültürüne saygı
duyan ve sahip çıkan bireylerin
yetişmesini sağlandığı bir sisteme
ihtiyacımız var bizim
öğrencileri doğru yanlış sayılarına göre
değil de
yeteneklerine ilgilerine ve hayallerine
göre bir yol çizme teşvik etmek Sizce de
birbirinden farklı çocukları Aynı
soruları çözmeye zorlamaktan aynı
sınavlarda yarıştırmaktan çoktan
mantıklı değil mi İşte Bizler Belki bu
temellere sahip bir eğitim felsefesini
benimsediğimiz takdirde
üniversitede bir bölüm bitirip yüklü ama
sahibi olan gençler geleceğin
belirsizliği içerisinde kıvranmayacaklar
diğer bir noktadan sürdürülebilirlik ve
eğitim arasındaki ilişkiyi şuradan
dikkat çekmek istiyorum
gittikçe karmaşıklaşan dünyamızda
problemlere çözüm bulabilme yetisine
sahip
olaylara farklı perspektiflerden
bakabilen ve de en önemlisi doğru
kararlar verebilen gençlerin
yetişmesinin ne kadar önemli olduğunun
hepimiz farkındayız bundan eminim
Çünkü geleceğe göre bilen ve buna göre
önlem alan gençler İçinde bulunduğumuz
100 yılın en önemli sorunlarını çözecek
anahtar Aslında değil mi peki ne gibi
sorunlardan bahsediyoruz iklim
değişikliği
gelir eşitsizliği işsizlik açlık
yoksulluk yolsuzluk ve aklınıza
gelebilecek daha birçok sorun
birleşmiş milletlerin 2030 yılına
kadarki sürdürülebilir kalkınma
hedeflerine bakarsak 4 maddede şunu
göreceğiz
herkese yaşam boyu kaliteli eğitim
imkanını sağlamak
işte Bizler bu eğitim felsefesini
benimsediğimiz ve uyguladığımız takdirde
Sürdürülebilir kalkınmayı başarıyla
gerçekleştiriyor olacağız yalnız
atlamamamız gereken çok önemli bir nokta
daha var o da şu Tabii ki konuşacağız
konuşmaya devam edeceğiz Ne de olsa hem
birey olarak hem de Toplum olarak
bilinçlenmemizde en önemli araç kuşkusuz
ki değildir Ancak sadece konuşmak yetmez
biz aklımızdaki yani teorideki
fikirlerimizi pratiğe geçirebildiğimiz
Yani uygulayabildiğimiz ve de
sonuçlarını görebileceğimiz müddetçe
başarılıyız O halde neden başlamıyoruz
ki Neden şu anda bir adım olarak
saymıyoruz Ben Beren Tunalı bugün burada
bir genç olarak sizlerin karşısında bu
adımı attığım için Kendimle gurur
duyuyorum Siz de kendinizle duyun
sürekli değişen ve dönüşen dünyamızda
değişimin kendisi olmak için çalışın
devam edin devam edelim kendi yolumuzu
kendimiz çizelim ve bu yoldan yürüyelim
daha iyi bir gelecek için teşekkürler
[Alkış]